yeah so this is donut donut coffee which
number one I'm already trying that you
know anything that with the words donut
in it I'm trying it's a donut penis like
a donut around a penis yeah it would be
like intentionally like what about
sucking the dick it'd be like trying to
get to the donut what about a candied
penis like a pickled or like what do you
mean like candy like it's like cover
like it's an actual penis but it's
covered like fried and vinegar no no no
like how do you candy something you you
just I was just imagine it's like right
with sugar right or whatever yeah it's
just like dipped in a like like a like a
vat of melted Jolly Ranchers or
something
[Laughter]
kitten little candied penis
they should start selling that at
Disneyland
jeez